pronto pronto scusa il tempo per una
merda sono mai capito caso è stato
solamente un caso mi fai schifo ti sei
fante ingiustificate che merda che
schifo te lo giuro che tu ti sei fatta
anche tu
anzi come il mio all'editoriale di
portali renos aula e si è fatta un
clistere col burro ma io devo e la
canzone calante ma che c'è di acquisire
bellezza era un cristo e ti dico 61
valentia se una vanesia sei pianeti che
siccome dorian gray senti adesso non mi
perché parlare francese corea non mani
pure che perdo soldi è parlato sia
culturali
a rovinare giornata una volta che ero
contenta lo status quo sempre un fondo
arrivata lei no non si fa così non si fa
così pronto a pezzo che mi spieghi
perché è scritto quella giusta ma chi te
se in culla quella specie dopo tutto
quello che ci mettete lo spazio
guarda la pace cucina o da perdere non
so se sia una mitomane mitomane mitomane
ma la storia dei pooh lenti dai ragazzo
certe persone angola
con il solo ora facciale tipo che va da
sé questa è una delle cose che il 99 per
cento delle persone che va su internet
diciamo più che altro sui social network
facebook twitter e compagnia bella fa
scrivere status con frecciatine insulti
che sono poi alla fine tutte quante
dirette a persone che conosciamo e con
le quali forse non abbiamo le palle di
parlare strano il mondo di internet che
poi per carità io sono il primo che ci
sguazza il primo che lo fa il primo che
adora la tecnologia cioè io e la
tecnologia siamo come il burro e
marmellata il pane con la nutella sailor
pluto e la vecchiaia voglio dire allora
è vero noi siamo la generazione 2.0 cioè
quelli che il computer non lo vedono
come una specie di quadrato luminescente
pieno di pornazzi informazioni fallaci
ma come una finestra sul mondo piena di
fornaci e informazioni sbagliate però è
una finestra sul mondo comunque dice
cosi anche se noi siamo la generazione
secondo secondo me ci sono delle cose
che tutti quanti facciamo nel momento in
cui entriamo in contatto con un social
network tutti quanti prima o poi vi
sparerete una posa in una foto la prima
cosa che farebbe più tardi nei bagni
perché quello che fanno tutti quanti in
maniera abusiva
comincerete a rick linari dietro il
collo per essere più belli poi magari di
riprendere tanti dall'alto e con una
cosa molto comune farti vedere
tantissimi con con i semini non vi
prendere sul serio e soprattutto
mostrerete naturalmente secondo me è uno
dei motivi per cui è bello avere un
social e perché sai dove potersi
lamentare uno degli status che le
persone amano più di tutti è quello di
scrivere che schifo qualcosa che tipo di
patrizia nella gente a differenza della
giant e cattiveria della gente
la crudeltà della gente in via della
gente la pochezza della gente che schifo
la gente ke skifo la
che bruci schifo a lazio che era in
crocefisse dalle chiazze la politica il
natale
ecco un'altra cosa era maggior parte
delle persone fa e quella di scrivere
tutto quello che passa per la testa come
se non ci fosse nessuno a leggerti dio
ha creato il mondo
io ho creato dio meno kia l'abramovich
credo l'ulisse di joyce io e patricia
amiche per sempre amore vero ombelico
del mondo
la bocca i locali
sia come stai per chi non si capiscono
mai nonnis oppone penna cosa amore è
come una banana ogni sua distrazione
sono diversità canzoni nero pasolini è
come un pack dei liguri
faccio un esempio questa come una frase
che io stesso ho scritto su twitter e
della quale ad oggi mi vergogno
però quando la scrissi per me era una
delle cose più [ __ ] che avessi mai
concepito mi senti un genio ci stanno un
sacco di altre cose che vengono fatte
sui social poi fatemi magari sapere
anche voi quale l'utilizzo che fate di
facebook e compagnia bella magari non
scrivete qua sotto